voici la liste officielle des douze
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
nathalie arthaud candidate de lutte
ouvrière déjà candidate en 2012 ou en
2017 nicolas dupont aignan candidat de
debout la france déjà candidat en 2012
et en 2017 anne hidalgo candidate du
parti socialiste pour la première fois
yannick jadot candidate d'europe
écologie les verts pour la première fois
jean lassalle candidats de résistons
déjà candidat en 2017 marine le pen
candidate du rassemblement national déjà
candidate en 2012 en 2017 emmanuel
macron candidat de la république en
marche déjà candidat en 2017 jean luc
mélenchon candidat de la france est
soumise déjà candidat en 2012 et 2017
valérie pécresse candidate les
républicains pour la première fois
philippe poutou candidat du nouveau
parti anticapitaliste déjà candidat en
2012 et 2017 fabien roussel candidat du
parti communiste pour la première fois
eric zemmour candidats de reconquête
pour la première fois